hey guys welcome back to another for
honor video and we're gonna be talking
about the fastest way that you can get
the Halloween loot from the for honor
feast of the Otherworld so you're
probably here because you want the new
loot the new battle outfits the ornament
and the new effect Down Under
now these outfits aren't that great
compared to the mask outfits but if you
don't want to spend steal and you want
exclusive items these are the next best
thing and they're not too bad but
compared to the mask outfits the mask
ones are way better in my opinion now
one of the things I noticed while doing
this about while playing this event is
that this thing has a lot of items
because for the effect downunder
you might get the effect but it's only
for one of them that being idol
execution or emo you don't get all three
once you want locker for the character
you only get one so you're gonna have to
weed through all the shitty [ __ ] just to
get to the loot you want which is why
I'm making this video in the first place
so that you guys can get your loot and
feel happy about it so the first thing
we need to do is find out what game mode
we're going to be playing for this I
tried every game mode that had an AI
mode fort which is just about everyone
because fighting AI is a lot easier to
fight than fighting players in the
fastest game what I found out is brawl
AI you can't do duel AI because they
said in the reddit post which I talked
about less or actually a couple days ago
and yesterday which was that you can't
play duel a AI because it's obviously
you're just gonna fight the by you're
gonna destroy and you're gonna get loot
super quickly so they deactivated all
Luke coming from duel AI you can do dual
versus dual and you probably could just
sit there all game and let the person
beat on you but what's the fun in that
so that's why I did brawl versus AI I
did every game mode and played five
matches then divided the times I got to
complete the match and got an average
the brawl ended up being the smallest
time which is about two minutes and 14
seconds as an average per match so then
took that time and divided it by an hour
just see how many matches I can get in
an hour and equal to about 26.8 or 27
matches if you want to round up now
obviously you're gonna have to take into
account of the time between matches the
downtime the intermission and even
queueing up but the time was too random
because sometimes maybe they'll leave
the game and then you'll have to find a
new opponent or they'll rematch right
away so don't bother adding it into the
equation but either way the main problem
that comes with this is that not
Matthieu play gets loot sometimes you do
sometimes you don't in those games I
wrote down how many games I got loot and
how many times I didn't get loot from
this event and it came out close to
about 66 percent four of the five
matches so basically two out of every
three matches was a loot drop which
isn't too bad but obviously this won't
be the same for everyone you might get
all loot in those five matches or you
might get zero loot in the matches it's
just completely random but once again
that's why you play brawl so you can get
these matches done quicker so you can
get the drop chances more faster
so just to recap either grab a friend or
be like me and play alone and wait for
someone to cue up play some brawl AI and
destroy those BOTS and get all that loot
but that's gonna be the end of the video
guys if you did find the video
informative or helpful then give it a
like it really does help me out
subscribe if you're new for more for
more content like news leaks and tips
and all that good stuff my two news
videos are gonna be popping up on screen
for you if you haven't watched those
already I mean that guys I'll see you
all later have a great rest of your
weekend
and peace out